his first season was called the year's
best show one of the year's best show
and the 16th best show of the year out
of an overall list of 31 and now he's
back
this seems unnecessarily large and in
season 2 he's changing everything up why
would I do that
oh that's a rough all bets are most
decidedly still on maybe he'll let a
pony oh I cannot look after a pony he'll
solve crime how with the pony with a
crime solving pony he'll be a single dad
struggling to raise an adorable child
whose actual baby is this and two sets
of multicultural twins okay
yeah respect my body space look we were
just really assuming the show is gonna
be basically the same last week tonight
season two more of basically the same
sure yeah
in spite of everything what does that
mean well you know keeping the glasses
why I need the glasses I can't see
without them same haircut I don't really
have much of an options it's kind of
lego man or nothing no improvements yeah
give us one more year
you